Finding lines in images
Let's talk about how we find line features.
In this example here we've taken a picture
of a church and have overlaid a number of
lines onto that image. These lines lay along
the obvious boundaries in the scene.
The boundary between the sky and the roof,
roof and the wall, edges and windows and so
on. How do we go about doing this? The first
step is we take our original input image,
we convert it to a gray scale image and then
we perform an age extraction operation.
We talked about edge operators in a previous
lecture. It involved essentially a convolutional
process to determine image gradients and then
we apply some threshold to that.
This image looks very impressive in a way
we can clearly see that all the obvious lines
in the image are highlighted here. But remember
that this is just an image. It contains a
whole lot of pixels. Some pixels are black
and some pixels are white. There is exactly
no concept of line here.
Our eyes are seeing lines within the scene
and our eyes and our brain are very, very
good at doing this but there is exactly no
notion of lines here. It is simply a bunch
of white pixels and black pixels and the white
pixels highlight where there is significant
grading within the scene.
So how do we find the long line segments here?
How do we group these white pixels into lines
which we can describe by a simple equation.
y=mx+b. The way we do this is with an image
processing technique called the half transform
and it's very, very ingenious and I want to try
and explain it as simply as I can.
Let's imagine that we have one edge point.
So this might be a pixel that's along the
roof of the church that we were just looking
at, a single pixel which lays on an edge.
Now there are infinite number of lines which
can go through any point in space. This line
for instance goes through the point, this
line does not go through, this line does go
through, this one doesn't, this one does,
this one does, this one does and this one
does.
Now we could consider that the lines vote
for the point. This line doesn't go through
the point so it's not allowed to vote for
the point. It gets zero votes. Then this line
gets zero votes as well; it doesn't go through
the point. But this line gets a vote and so
does this one, this one, this one and this
one.
These lines voted for the point and the red
lines have not voted for the point.
Now, lets consider we have another point which
lays along the edge perhaps these two black
points now lay along the roof of the church
that we were just looking at. Once again there
are an infinite number of lines which could
go through that point. Could be this line,
or this line, or this line and once again,
we are going to allow the lines to vote for
a point.
So this line gets one vote because it goes
through a point, this line gets a vote as
does this one and this one but this line also
goes through that first point.
That particular line now has two votes. But
we see that there are a lot of lines in this
scene and I have already drawn up a small
number. There are a infinite number of lines
that go through the points, infinite number
of lines that don't go through the points.
We can see that some of the lines that go
through a point get one vote but one particular
line, the line that goes through two points
gets two votes. So we've used a simple voting
system to try and determine the best line
that goes through two points and we can extend
this to a large number of points and that's
what we would do when we process an image
like the church. Normally when we represent
lines, we use an equation like this. This
is the very standard Cartesian representation
of a line. U is our horizontal coordinate,
V is our vertical coordinate, M is the gradient
and C is the intercept. A problem with this
particular representation of a line is for
vertical lines. In the case where the line
is vertical, it must be equal to infinity
and that's slightly problematic.
There is another way we can describe the equation
of a line and we do it in this fashion, it's
often called the polar representation of a
line that we have a U and V coordinates but
the line is described by two parameters now
rho and theta. Theta is the angle that the
line makes with the horizontal axis and rho is the perpendicular distance between the
origin and a point on the line. Two parameters
rho and theta can describe a line in a more
versatile way than the traditional gradient
and intercept formulation.
One problem is when we are talking about all
those infinite number of lines that could
go through a point is its going to be difficult
for an infinite number of lines to vote. What
we need to do is to quantize the values of
rho and theta. Instead of considering an infinite
number of lines we consider a finite number
of lines.
It works like this, it's a voting scheme now
we have a coordinate system, horizontal axis
is the line parameter of theta, the vertical
axis is the line parameter of rho. And we
placed a grid on this. Every single cell represents
a possible line in an image. A particular
value of row and a particular value of theta
and that represents a line in the image. This
is a very course example in a real world example
this grid might have hundreds of elements
in both directions. The important thing to
keep in mind is that
each cell represents a particular line within the image.
For any point in the input image, that lays
along an edge, that's a pixel at coordinate U
and V the parameters of the lines that go
through that point must satisfy this particular equation.
This is now an equation that relates rho to theta. For every possible value of theta,
given that I know U and V, I can computer
a value of rho. And so all these lines get
to have a vote. They get to vote one for that
particular line. For this one point, it puts
these votes into what we call the voting array
sometimes called the Hough accumulator.
So for one point we have made votes for a
large number of lines. Now let's consider
what happens when we introduce a second point.
The second point is voting for all of the
possible lines that pass through it and it's introduced another curve into the voting
array. We can see that there are a number
of possible lines that got one vote and we
can see that there is one line here which
has got two votes. This is the underlying
principle for the Hough transform.
We will have a quick look at the scaling variant
and feature transform.
And here it is. Now to compute the sift features
I use the toolbox function isift, I parse
in the image and very similar arguments as
we used for the Harris corner function and
I am going to select 200 corner features.
Just take a minute or two to compute and now
in the workspace we have a vector of 200 sift
point features.
Let's have a look at one of these features.
Let's have a look at the first one in the
vector. It's called a coordinate of 289.9
and 805.4 it has a number of additional attributes
like the Harris corner it's got a strength
which indicates how distinctive that feature
is but unlike the Harris corner feature, it
also has an orientation, a theta value and
also a scale value.
Let's have a look at this particular feature
in the image. We do that by calling the plot
method on it, we are going to plot it in yellow,
I am going to exaggerate it's scale so it's
a bit easier to see. I will exaggerate the
scale by a factor of 16 and I am going to
display it in clock format and I will explain
that in just a moment.
There we see the feature. Drawn a circle around
it and the circle indicates something about
the scale of the feature and the line which
is the hand of the clock it's what the clock
option is about says something about the orientation
of the particular feature.
Now we can display the sift features for the
whole image. To do that, I am going to redisplay
the original scene draw it a little darker
and then I am going to plot all of the features
in white and we exaggerate the scale a bit
less this time and I am going to display them
as clocks. And there we see it.
Each feature has a coordinate, a point within
the image. For each feature we draw a circle
around it and the size of the circle indicates
something about the scale of the feature.
A small circle indicates a pattern of pixels
that's quite distinct across that very small
spatial scale within the image.
So it might be a single leaf, it might be
a small corner of a balcony or a window in
the image. A large circle corresponds to a
large scale feature.
So that's something that is distinctive at
a much larger spatial scale so it might be
the general idea of a bright building surrounded
by some dark trees along the bottom edge.
There is a lot of information in the position
of the feature also in its scale.
Each circle has got a single radial line and
that corresponds to the orientation of the
feature that is saying something about how
that pattern of pixels is oriented within
the image.
Imagine now I move my camera somewhat dramatically.
Perhaps I rotated it by 90 degrees or perhaps
I moved much further away from the building.
The great advantage of the sift feature is
that it will allow me to match features between
these two very different views.
Although the orientation of the pattern of
pixels in the scene will be different although
the scale of the pattern of pixels will be
different, the sift algorithm is able to see
through that. And you will find the same interesting
point in each of the two very, very different
views. But we will report that the orientation
has changed or that the scale of the feature
has changed.
In addition to having a position and an orientation
and a scale the sift feature also has a descriptor
and we can have a look at the descriptor for
feature number one.
And we can see here in the workspace the new
variable D and it is a 128 element vector.
The sift algorithm describes the pattern of
pixels within the circle, what we call the
support region by 128 element vector. So that's
quite a comprehensive description of that
particular pattern of pixels. If we have
these two very, very diverse views of the same
scene even though the orientation and the
scale might be very, very different.
The descriptors associated with the interest
points in the two scenes will be very very
similar and we can evaluate the similarity
of points between these two scenes simply
by comparing their two descriptive vectors
and typically that's done in the Euclidian
sense by the square root of the sum of the
squares of the difference between the two
descriptive vectors.
Now this has been a very cursory introduction
to the idea of sift features. They're very very
important in computer vision unfortunately
in this introductory course, it's not possible
to say very much more about this. There is
a lot of literature and you will find mention
of them in many computer vision textbooks.